[Music]
all right controversial Netflix hosts
so-called comedian Chelsea Handler has
officially now entered the realm of
unhinged despite portraying herself as a
champion for gay rights the late night
host launched an old vile vicious
homophobic rant on Twitter against
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham sweet
is so graphic so despicable well we're
not even going to show it to you on the
program but it's safe to say that in
Chelsea's world decency is only reserved
for liberal friends of course this kind
of repulsive behavior from handler is
nothing new in December handler tweeted
out a promo for a show featuring a
mean-spirited parody of White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders here with
reaction Fox News contributor Tommy
learned Lehren is with us you know Tommy
here's the thing I'm not gonna call for
a firing boycott I don't do it for Bill
Maher that idiot Stephen Colbert I don't
care what people say everyone has the
power to change the channel but if we
say something that is deemed as
conservatives inappropriate they want
our head on a chopping block then begins
the boycotts then begins the silencing
what's your reaction well we have to
point out the hypocrisy especially to
individuals like Chelsea Handler who
continued to display this pattern and
you know what I gotta tell you Tom I am
so sick of these Hollywood liberals who
sit at their award shows and their pearl
clutching they're talking about speaking
your truth me two times up there for
everyone and then they tweet crap like
this that's disgusting and vile and yet
we're supposed to buy this whole charade
that there are these wonderful moral
people
no no not falling for it all right let
me show a little bit you actually
debated her and I remember reading about
it I thought let's remind people a
little bit about what happened I do
believe that he's a good president I do
believe that he's done things and people
talk about all the time and so well he
tweeted something and that's mean I can
get over the meanness of his tweets if
he's helping middle-class Americans if
he's helping America if he's putting
America first he strengthening us on the
world stage
he's enforcing our border I can deal
with the mean tweet but why but but what
but but it mean mean represents so many
other things he's he's kind of like a
toddler like an angry you know he's a
toddler he's lashes out at people and
he's vengeful and he says really nasty
things what is she saying
she's acting like a toddler well of
course she is she's also the person that
organized the the women's March the the
pink hat March at Sundance Film Festival
last year this woman although I did have
a decent conversation with her since
then she's just gone off the deep end I
don't know if it's because she lost her
show at Netflix or she doesn't know what
she's doing now she wants to be an
activist I don't know but I thought that
she was at least somewhat level-headed
and I used the thing she was funny but
she's like the rest of these so-called
comedians they inject politics that they
don't understand they know nothing about
into their acts and then not only are
they not funny they're disgusting and
yet they get away with it because
they're on the left as usual what do you
think of her personally personally I
have to be honest with you Sean she was
very kind to me
she was respectful we had a good
conversation I can't say the same about
other liberals that I've debated debated
or shared the stage with but she was she
was very nice one of the big liberals I
didn't know you were doing that oh boy
Trevor Noah
Bill Maher all the ladies of the view I
mean let's join the list I was just in
West Hollywood earlier today talking to
a bunch of the loving and tolerant left
I put myself in these situations because
I hope for a productive conversation I
think I have one with Chelsea but my
goodness that doesn't mean I'm not gonna
rip her apart for what she's doing on
Twitter because I find it disgusting I
find it hypocritical and she needs to be
called out all right we look forward to
the next Tommy Lehren hits the road
we'll show it right here on Hannity
Tommy good to see you thanks for being
with us